that's one just shotgun these all real
quick I'm kidding
what's up GQ I am ninja and these are my
essential items my first essential item
are my fare dynamic headphones that I
use when I games they're open aired
which is super important and they're
incredibly comfortable the sound quality
is fantastic these are not noise
canceling you know I came at home so I
don't want my wife to you don't
constantly hear me yelling all the time
they're open here I can hear myself very
well when I'm talking these are my Bose
headphones these are noise canceling so
when I'm traveling all the time I'm on
planes and things like that it's just
great to be able to block out the baby
crying in the back of the plane listen
to my music fall asleep or get super
into movies and Netflix shows that I'm
downloading I'm traveling my paste for
my hair so I've been using pretty much
the same style of hair paper for a long
time I think you want that greasy look
you know what that wet hair look still
like okay I used to rock that when I was
younger man I didn't know anything about
this stuff so my mom bought it for me
but now yeah I styled my hair pretty
much everyday with some clay and it's
it's the look man it's how I get the
flow of the flip and how it stays in
place the ninja air 58 final mouse
literally it's like 58 grams this thing
is like the lightest Mouse in the market
I originally relied heavily on a lot of
like side buttons on the mouse but I
started using this for like a week I
broke down had a bad day I was like I'm
going back I'm gonna go back to my old
Mouse and I literally mean I plugged it
in for one game got destroyed because it
was too heavy took it threw it out put
it back in and I've never looked back I
literally used this every single day to
game and this is what I destroy my
enemies with some forward I'm in super
essential my fourth essential item is
literally with me at all times I have
not taken it off since I've gotten
married and that is my wedding ring I
love my wife absolutely with all my
heart so I never take it off even for
you know showering anything like that
I literally have with me more than any
item that I have here I've been wearing
hoodies my entire life any competition
whatsoever I would always put a hoodie
on and then I put my jersey on over my
hoodie and a lot of venues when I was
competing professionally there's always
super cold in the venue's as well so I
always needed a hoodie
singing in German fantastic these are my
Gucci sweats I honestly have been
wearing sweat pants my entire life more
so than I have worn jeans which wasn't
always you know the coolest thing to do
but it was always the most comfortable
and I just liked in comfortable I feel
out of my my Zen when I'm wearing jeans
which I am wearing them right now or
sweats every single day my life I was
the best job ever so insanely essential
these are my Louie Vuitton shoes I love
the white with the blue denim it just
looks fantastic they're a little dirty
and that's because I was an idiot and
wore these to a marshmallow concert I'd
go out with these all the time I'd have
fun need some new pairs but again every
time I go into the store they don't have
my size in any of the shoes that I want
to try on I want to wear cuz I got big
feet size 13 my Samsung Galaxy Note 9
super reliable the battery life I feel
like literally lasts forever you know I
had this every single day this is where
I upload my Instagram clips my Twitter
clips also if I'm mobile and I don't get
the game a lot I will throw it out so
for night and and it just handles the
game really well it can now run at 60fps
which is fantastic so super essential
need it every day that's a great
question need a thing love you too my
brother Chris but I didn't say yes of
the other word